sneaky snake hey there you're gonna need
to get past that snake you'll be fine if
you don't wake it up what happens if you
wake it up that's naked sneaky
horrifying
this is horrifying trick the snake
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha Pass sneaky snake not
so sneaky anymore now me am I went in my
mind joke's on you I didn't like my legs
oh not like that I'll take it you know
Oh
and gun I don't know what that means but
it can't be good supported me my mom
stair survival this is the most fun
you've ever had let's try this the way
that it wants without the flying
cheaters link can be v boink okay
so far so goo Wow well lost son can't be
bothered about that at the moment in a
bit of a predicament hi sorry
okay can you win Oh escape the ship hi
sergeant you're trying to escape a
military ship but there are red bad guys
everywhere escape the ship alive if you
want a bit of a challenge try keeping
your son alive I don't know if I'm on
dude Biscay game II don't know why
there's a battle ax there I'm killing up
a storm over here eat your corpse out of
the way through yeah all right this time
it's gonna be different
why gravity was really high in that one
area but thank you Victory's gonna be
mine [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you
[ __ ] you to [ __ ] me right up your butt
old man well give me main deck
I think the box well sure is gonna do a
Netflix 100 this is worth a massive
girth doesn't do this backflip well that
was supposed to be backwards but then I
can't be picky when it comes to what's
there to do excellent this time that's
what said it was looking for there's one
max flowers at Richter not ones that I
use ourselves backflipping maybe I am
maybe I'm not maybe I'm a sassy vana
today what helps it cook it in the elbow
whoa [ __ ] slow who goes slow no one
losers that's who like my side I fell
behind one slow [ __ ] ah whoa air air
ball oh my god it's a sport I put it in
my goal I'm such an [ __ ]
give me the ball give me the ball get
away from a teammate
I'll body slam you right into the ground
don't make me pull an epic suplex yeah
this now now I never mind we're just
gonna have an orgy and our goal net Hey
I've always wanted to tell you how much
I love you their career your air
I'm gonna consider that as actions that
I did and not random fate rope fall well
do I have any control in the matter here
or am I just a victim of gravity and
happenstance [ __ ] [ __ ] this has been
happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye